bonjour et bienvenue sur maps est captée
dans votre émission vivre ensemble
aujourd'hui nous abordons le sujet du
métier d'assistante maternelle avec
madame tarby assistantes maternelles au
moufia
monsieur fontaine assistants maternels à
saint-andré et madame gaz puéricultrice
au département tous les parents ont été
confrontés au choix du mode de garde de
leurs enfants
le métier d'assistante maternelle est
une solution même gaz
expliquez nous en quoi consiste ce
métier c'est une personne qui accueille
à son domicile les enfants mineurs dans
des conditions propres à assurer leur
bon développement physique intellectuel
et affectif
quelles sont les conditions à remplir
pour exercer le métier d'assistant
maternel
alors pour pouvoir exercer le métier
d'assistant maternel il faut au
préalable obtenu un agrément et pour
cela certaines conditions s'avèrent
nécessaires donc il faut que la personne
soit majeur qu'elle puisse vraiment
maîtriser le français oral que son
casier judiciaire soit vierge et la
personne
doit pouvoir garantir aussi ça va de soi
la santé l'épanouissement la sécurité de
l'enfant est avant tout exercice
d'accueil
l'assistant maternel doit
obligatoirement suivre aussi une
formation obligatoire d'accords
bilatéraux
est ce que le logement entre également
en ligne de compte tout à fait le
logement
aussi effectué l'accueil des enfants va
répondre à des critères d'hygiène de
confort l'espace et de sécurité très
bien alors une fois cet agrément obtenu
est ce que les services de pmi
protection maternelle et infantile du
département garde un contact avec
l'assistante maternelle
oui tout à fait
l'assistante maternelle ou reste en
contact avec les services de pmi
la puéricultrice bientôt elle est là
pour accompagner l'instant maternelle au
début de l'exercice professionnel
et puis par la suite dans le cadre d
extension d renouvellement d'agrément
des demandes d'actualisation il ya
forcément un nouveau décompte des
campagnes tout à fait très bien
alors cette assistante maternelle à
domicile est-ce que et elle est employée
elle ou il d'ailleurs est employé par le
parent ou par le département
alors ce sont les parents qui sont les
employeurs corps des assistants
maternels très bien alors comme nous
pouvons le constater aujourd'hui il y a
quelques uns parmi les assistants
maternels
oui il y en a quelques-uns d'où le se
font-elles et ses présents aujourd'hui
voilà que les rencontrer lors de la
demande d'agrément
alors madame terbi vous êtes assistants
maternels sur le secteur du moufia
depuis combien de temps vous exercer ce
métier
j'habite au mont fia ça fait 22 ans que
je suis à se servir d'elle que je garde
des enfants que et c'est un boulot
vraiment exceptionnel je dirais parce
que il faut aimer les enfants et avoir
le contact avec des enfants c'est
formidable oui qu'est ce qui me plaît le
plus dans votre jeu justement mais moi
c'est les enfants
si le contact d'enfants et cadets foi
catholique cafard voyage gamin qui vous
fait un grand sourire vous oubliez
carrément ce que vous avez dans la tête
et puis vous sourient aux caméras y ça
vous donne la joie quand ça je sais pas
je trouvais pas les mots pour dire mais
c'est vraiment génial de travailler les
endroits jeu j'adore mon métier en tout
cas et c'est formidable on l'entend tout
car
vous verrez à gré pour accueillir
combien d'enfants je suis agréé pour
quatre enfants pour le moment j'ai deux
petites filles que je garde et une en
périscolaire d'accord donnez nous un peu
les prénoms de ses tubes et mc new nous
les petits bouts d'choux s'appelle
aliciens ça fait quatre ans que je la
garde va à l'école elle est en
périscolaire
je garde les ria qui aura 3 2 ans demain
on va faire une petite fête pour son
anniversaire et je garde génial ça fait
pas longtemps ça fait deux mois et j'ai
gardé sa grande soeur il ya trois ans
prévient alors les relations avec les
parents ça se passe comment super super
super c'est incroyable après je veux
dire quand ils sont actrices ont bien
accueilli on discute on paie des
conditions au départ oui c'est pas
pendant le travail qu'on a en effet les
conditions il faut remplir un contrat de
travail et après tout s'enchaîne
automatiquement vous adapter aux
demandes des parents au pas aux demandes
des parents parce que il ya des parents
qui commencent à travailler il ya des
femmes
un film bien qu'ils sont
oui qui n'ont personne d'autre que la
maman paul dardé donc si elle commence à
travailler à 6 heures du matin il faut
qu'elle fasse la route du mont fia a
aussi un chu de belles pierres donc il
faut quand même un laps de temps peut
faire le parcours 1
il faut calculer le pack de la maman est
aussi les oreilles et il faut que
l'assistant maternel soit disponible il
faut que ça de disponibles moi j'ai de
la chance d'avoir un mari qui à la
retraite et qui qui peut aussi y avait
eu à intervenir au cas où et d une peau
m'aider dans mon métier a bien aidé il a
il adore les enfants aussi on a des
petits enfants on n'a pas y'a pas de
réseau pour le pas et me dit bon bah
c'est faire ces fontaines
vous êtes assistants maternels qui vous
a poussé à exercer ce métier encore très
féminin c'est qui m'a poussé à ce métier
c'est ma femme elle été digérée système
majoritaire à la maison donc je voyais
tout le temps avec ses enfants
j'étais un petit peu à la cage leye on
va dire que je suis en aiguille ça m'a
attiré j le maximum plus d'accord et
vous exerciez un autre métier auparavant
oui j'étais dans le bâtiment d'accord
alors vous avez choisi d'exercer en
maisons d'assistants maternels
pourquoi c'est à la maison et par
rapport à la loi des enfants ce que j'ai
trois filles ou nuls
on était on aurait été trop à la maison
face à des enfants ma femme gars plus
les vols ça aurait été trop beau et trop
d'accord dont on avait rejoint voilà l
oms
i'm on en fait l'homme d'accord c'était
avec des assistants maternels que vous
connaissez déjà
oui on connaissait déjà d'accord madame
connaissez déjà de phase iib sont massés
hier on a fait une petite réunion de
discussion on s'est organisé et de là on
est parti pour faire une main c'est une
façon de fonctionner qui vous plaît oui
ça ne sommes pas très bien une bonne
entente n'équipe vraiment soudé comme on
dit ce qu'on a créé la mort avec le
monde et a fait avec on connaît bien les
amusant oui donc ce soutien bien par
rapport aux enfants tout ça c'est bien
même gaz alors la maison d'assistantes
maternelles c'est un concept encore
relativement récent expliquez-nous de
quoi il s'agit alors depuis la loi du 9
juin 2010 les instants maternelles
peuvent travailler en dehors de leur
domicile
donc 2 à 4 maximum peuvent s'organiser
travailler ensemble au sein d'une maison
des soins maternels et accueillir au
maximum 16 enfants
très bien alors à ce jour combien de
mamans été créés dans l'île alors
actuellement il y en a une qui a été
agréé tout récemment donc il ya dix-sept
maisons d'assistants maternels pour une
capacité de 222 enfants et
lien je crois 58 ans en maternelle qui
travaillent au sein du team assistants
maternels s'écrit souvent féminins mais
désormais grâce à la mam de s'entendre
et deux masculins définitivement adopté
la maison d'assistants maternels la
castille marmaille a retenu cette
originalité en plus de louise christine
et amandine il faudra aussi compter avec
david à
ça me plaît et c'est afin de voir ma
femme travaille et qu'ils enfants tous
les jours j'ai aidé et ça me plaît
j'aime bien les enfants apparemment jeu
mais ils maisons d'assistants maternels
mixte la conseillère départementale a
souligné cette première sur toute l'île
d'une main mixte puisque nous comptons
un homme qui est très peu commun dans ce
métier j'ai envie de vous dire monsieur
que vous avez fait un choix courageux et
admirable une maison où mettre les
compétences en commun mais surtout pour
sortir de l'isolément de la mission
d'assistance maternelle comme christine
qui en appartement avait du mal à
exercer sa profession
jao j'habitais j'avais du mal à pouvoir
travailler
j'étais dans mon appartement n'avait
déjà discuté ça fait un bon moment avec
des collègues mais après on a monté le
projet ça m'a pris du temps mais
maintenant ça c'est un boutinon
ce qu'on a fait la solidarité puisque en
additionnant tous les agréments nos
quatre assistants maternels peuvent
accueillir jusqu'à 13 marmaille la
maison d'assistants maternels permet
aussi cela obtenir de nouveaux agréments
on a su aussi la main pour justement que
monsieur compagne puisse travailler
quand ils n'avaient pas la possibilité
d'avoir l'agrément à son domicile et en
même temps ça a permis à deux autres
assistants maternels d'avoir des places
supplémentaires qui n'auraient pas pu
obtenir leur domicile et métiers
d'assistant maternel est une véritable
vocation il exerçait en main permet de
continuer à faire du périscolaire comme
moi j'ai aussi des scolaire a
aussi
il allait chercher à l'école et tout ça
doublage maintenant je peux laisser avec
mes collègues les autres et puis aller
chercher la faute et à l'école
donc c'est moins contraignant c'est une
structure qui plaît aux parents surtout
attiré par la vie en communauté que
propose la même on l'a choisi en fait
c'est notre assistante maternelle qui
nous en a parlé
effectivement nous ça nous a bien
convenu parce qu'on trouvait que c'était
un très bon compromis entre prise en
charge individuelle outre en avait quand
même son assistante maternelle et en
même temps l'apprentissage de la vie en
collectivité qui m'a bien préparé à
l'école donc pour nous c'était vraiment
idéal et on a accompagné notre
assistante maternelle dans ce projet
avec dix-huit maisons d'assistants
maternels à la réunion le conseil
départemental offre la possibilité à
travers ses structures d'une prise en
charge différente pour permettre aux
assistants maternels de sortir de chez
eux et de mettre en commun leur savoir
et le département encourage la création
des stress de ces structures les maisons
d'assistantes maternelles qu'elle
dispositif a été créé à ce sujet alors
il y à une aide financière de 4000 euros
qui est accordée par le département
depuis décembre 2013 pour les
aménagements
les travaux d'aménagement et
d'équipement de la même très bien
monsieur fontaine vous qui êtes en la
messe que vous avez bénéficié de ce
dispositif des aides du département
oui on a fait la demande à sa réponse
d'accord c'est en cours dans ce sens
court très bien alors vous avez
participé à la création de la maison
d'assistants maternels depuis le début
racontez-moi un peu comment ça se passe
et ben il faut déjà y équipe on a fait
une équipe
on est fier tous sont nés à quatre on
est très fier de nous après il ya eu les
démarches des administratifs que là et
c'est ce qu'on va dire ça pas de
combattre parce que il ya quand même des
trucs à faire pas mal de dossiers en
moyenne entreprise pour la même oui pas
mal le security pour l'enfant ah oui
avec ça c'était très important
oui c'est si tout ça que les ossis sont
basiques
non quand même assez compliqué on va
dire parce que bon il ya beaucoup de
propriétaires qui s'était bâtie sans ils
veulent pas on est tombé sur un banc
parisien qui est très gentil ben ouais
line up to me vous avez une courette ce
ne sont pas vos jouets comme le
président hassan ancien directeur
d'école d'accord il est déjà
sensibilisés à la question des petits
exactement très bien alors vous proposer
des horaires atypiques
expliquez-nous un peu lesquels bain par
rapport aux parents il ya des parents
qui les forêts il servait yeux ils sont
entre 530 et fanny des fois quand ils
remontent de sani le soir à 17 heures et
il ya des embouteillages
encore un accident dans une eau bio
parents toujours si un problème
un petit message on est toujours là
d'accord les heures voilà flexible vous
le samedi matin aussi également d'accord
très bien mais mme tarby vous ça vous
intéresserait goût d'exercer en maison
d'arrêt a personnellement je préfère sa
fille
j'ai 22 ans de métier donc j'ai
maintenant j'ai mes repères les
empoisonneurs leur pays fait bientôt et
je suis bien chez moi j'y vois là on est
avec vous et bien chez maeva et marielle
à la retraite je pourrais par
l'abandonner au bon chacun trouve son
bonheur dans un structure le médecin
maintenait ses consignes et la vie
familiale et la vie professionnelle
donc c'est normal que madame terbi aille
dans ce sens ou ipad
alors madame gaz régulièrement nous
entendons comment des places pour
accueillir nos petits qu'en est il pour
les assistants maternels du à gré du
département alors actuellement il y a
quand même 4191 place sur le département
et ce qu'on sait c'est qu'elle ne sont
pas toutes occupées
donc il y a des places disponibles et
pour les parents qui souhaitent utiliser
donc que ce mode de garde
les parents peuvent se renseigner auprès
des centres de pmi ou éventuellement
consulter le site du conseil
départemental donc trois wcg.se g9 7,4
bref un café rubrique aux briques
enfants s'en trouver une assistante
maternelle trouver une assistante
maternelle avis aux parents qui sont
intéressés voilà alors assistant
maternel à domicile assistants maternels
ram je suis parent qu'est ce que vous me
conseiller alors comme on vient de le
dire oui que vous voulez parler des
avantages faire moi je dirais que ça
dépend un petit peu des personnes autant
par la maternelle comme l'apprécient tôt
notre dame terminé son choix de tout âge
et à son domicile
donc il ya des personnes qui préfèrent
travailler seule chez elle alors que
d'autres ben justement vont préférer
vraiment différencier le côté profession
et le côté
famille tout à fait là et pour les
parents et pour les parents un certains
parents vont faire le choix de l'accueil
collectif et d'autres vont plutôt
préféré le cocon familial au domicile de
la saison maternelle moi j'ai
expérimenté les deux structures
collectives et l'assistante maternelle à
domicile
voilà vous en savez plus maintenant sur
le métier d'assistant maternel mam gaz
va vous donner tout de suite la démarche
à suivre pour devenir assistante
maternelle si vous aussi ça vous
intéresse
les personnes qui souhaitent exercer la
profession d'assistante maternelle
doivent au préalable s'inscrire à une
réunion d'information en contactant le
service etc et instruction nord et sud
donc en faisant le numéro suivant 02 62
21 25 08 pour la région nord-est et le
numéro 02 62 57 98 57 pour la région sud
ouest et à l'issue de la réunion les
personnes intéressées pourront récupérer
donc un dossier de demande d'agrément de
les personnes aussi qui souhaitent
obtenir plus d'informations peuvent
consulter le site du conseil
départemental donc www.cegedim.fr 4
point fr dans la rubrique enfance donc
trouver une assistante maternelle ou
obtenir des renseignements comment
devenir une est
notre mission s'achève je remercie nos
invités je vous donne rendez vous dans
une prochaine émission vivre ensemble à
très bientôt si on avait 7 4 télé
enfin